Michael McIntyre. Welcome.
Hey, Hey. Hi. Hi Fred. I'm wearing the same suit.
I'm wearing the same suit as the Netflix special ed. I'm so sorry. I forgot.
It's so rare that I've left the house for the last six months.
It was so exciting to wear a suit and he possessed one outfit.
Or is that the only one that actually fits you these days?
My, it doesn't fit me. I can't even do it up anymore, so it's getting worse,
but no, yeah, that that's true. Now I've decided sitting is, is more difficult.
Yes,
but I do have other clothes that I think it's important that everybody remembers
that. Um, so you are in Norway. Whereabouts in Norway, are you Frederick.
Slow with a young Thomas is a famous stylist and a in Oslo.
I knew you would.
Thomas, how would you style me? What's lacking here.
What do you think? Well.
Let's, let's go on a little shopping spree.
When, when we can travel again, I'll come to London and we'll go shopping. Well,
this is [inaudible],
That's the only thing I have in my diary at the moment.
So thank you so much for that.
We also, we also have sweetened with us with the, uh,
ex ex uh, leader of the labor party in Sweden, uh,
mano saline and a fellow non-Indian David ballpark.
Hi, David Mona. Very good. Thank you.
What's an extraordinary moment in circumstances to meet you in Sweden. Um,
this might be the,
I'm going to confidently say this is probably the only time we'll ever meet.
I mean, that's no disrespect, but I see all paths crossing again.
So let's make the most of this guys, I think, is it.
Tell me, are you, I mean, your show is called Shonan,
are you a, obviously you are a show, man. We can see that from the,
from the clips of the, uh, of the show, but, but, but,
but are you a showman at all times,
or do you have moments where you just don't want to be a show? Man?
I am not. Listen. I didn't want to be a show band when, uh,
when all this started at the beginning of, uh,
at the beginning of the pandemic, it marked when it, when we went into lockdown,
um, which is amazing because I recorded this show a week before. So this was,
you know, this is a record of the lights, the last performance I ever did.
It's the last time I was an official showman.
And then a few weeks later we'll know I wasn't Frederick. I was, uh,
I was a Baker and a hairdresser and a teacher and all the things we had to
do at home. Um,
it was just amazing to have the rug pulled out from under,
like we all have across the world. Um, um, from,
from beneath you and suddenly have to, you know, re readjust because I,
you know, my family have no respect for me.
I have noticed that I'm not a comedy star in their eyes,
especially my teenage sons. I'm a very annoying person.
I've only done this Netflix thing to try and appear cool to them in some way.
Um, and that's not working anyway. They're watching other things on Netflix,
even though I'm now on Netflix. Um, but now, now I'm coming out of it.
I'm out of the house.
I've got the suit back on and you're helping me feel like a show, man,
all over again.
Hi. Hi.
[inaudible].
Just the moments you're at all times to make sure that I'm healthy. So.
It's.
Very, very low. I don't know if it's broken.
It's fine.
No, I'm fine. I'm absolutely.
Fine. But do they have these.
Frederick? Do they have these annoying?
Yes. Yes. We have them.
I think we use them to cure asthma.
This is a thermometer. And when you go to a restaurant in London, they,
they shoot you like this to make sure that you're allowed it and you don't have
a temperature. And they do. My whole family went out for lunch today.
Every single one of us was the right temperature. Then I ordered chicken.
They under cooked. It we've shown up at the right temperature.
The least they can do is get the chicken at the right temperature.
I want to talk to you about the Norwegian language.
I was on the front page of a Norwegian newspaper when I announced some shows in,
in Bergen. Bergen. Yeah, that's perfect.
But that again, bad again.
So I said a completely different word Bergen, but it's bad again,
bad again for me is when something buy something at a good price.
So I went to the bathroom where apparently it's the rainiest place in the world.
This is the, this is right. You know this?
Yeah, it's quite wet there. Yeah.
I got in the taxi in the airport and the guy had his windscreen wipers on,
but it wasn't raining. So it was making a massive, annoying noise, you know?
And I said, excuse me, it's not raining. And he just turned around to win.
[Inaudible].
They had me on the front page and it said I was the humor.
What does that? The King of humor.
It's so bad.
And when my children disrespect me, I go, how dare you say that to the human.
It sounds impressive. I agree. Yeah. I'm still fine. It's still fine.
I love Norway. Norway has been so good for me and I love Sweden. I did,
but Norway prefer me. So I, I, I, I,
I need to build my presence in Sweden, but no, I did a gig in Stockholm,
but in Norway I've been to Oslo and Stavanger and,
um, Christian sand and Bergen and throne time
in Trump time, I came out of the airport. It, you know,
the revolving door and I came,
it was so icy that I slipped under the car that was picking me up and
nobody knew what.
Everyone was like, going Miko. Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey,
I was under the car screaming,
but tell me apart from, apart from Scandinavia.
Yeah. Fantastic. Yes.
That's some place as well. So cold, so cold.
There's just a ski jump and everyone's just, it's crazy place.
Crazy know interrupting you.
No, my question was, I mean, if we're talking about touring,
which is a, which is, uh,
might be a possibility again in the future and what, what, what,
what would be your favorite continent to tour apart from
Scandinavia?
There is nowhere else. Scandinavia
is my favorite continent.
Because you're moving all over the road. No.
I love, I love Scandinavia. I love the people I love.
They love their English is incredible.
The first show I ever did in Oslo,
I w I slowed everything down and I needed actually to speed it up. You know,
I was talking slowly because it's not your first language,
but the standard of English in Norway is far superior than
anything I've experienced in England.
But, but tell me, how have you, uh, I mean, your wife, you, you,
you, you talk a lot about your wife and your kids.
Are they always okay with that? Or does it happen that they get annoyed?
Um, my boys, not so much, they don't get to know it because I, I always, um,
I sort of hide it from them a little bit and that they, you know,
they're at that age where they don't think their dad is cool. I mean,
I don't know if you've got kids, how old they are, but it gets to the point.
Like, I, I used to drive my son to school and it's not so far away.
This school we could walk, but he always wanted me to drive him. Um, nah,
the other day we got into the car, I hadn't even turned the car on and he said,
dad, can you just drop me off here?
And we hadn't even gone anywhere because he's so embarrassed to be with me
anymore. So they are in no way, um,
watching everything I do so I can get away with a lot, I think.
And also the jokes I have about them is when they were much younger.
So they're not really that person anymore, if that makes sense,
because they were toddlers. And you know, I've got about when they were babies,
but my, my wife has a slightly different story.
She's had to put up with quite a lot. So I've made all sorts of jokes. Um,
I mean a big one I had was her putting tights on. And I talked about, you know,
when you get the tights,
how the beginning bit is quite sexy when you put the tight on the lower leg and
you know, when do you have tights? Is that a thing? Or.
W w I don't wear them. I don't, but I know of it. Yes.
It was putting our tights on one day when she was, you know,
hiking it all up and putting them all out like that. And I said,
that is very funny, darling. I might make jokes about that. And she said,
I don't think any other woman does that. Well, it turns out they all do it.
And that became one of my biggest jokes.
And always people come up to us and say, Oh, you're the one with the tights.
And I did make jokes, which I regret about her farting in her sleep,
which wasn't even true. And that was when I maybe maybe pushed the,
pushed it too far.
How, how did, how did he meet your wife? She was.
Um,
she was a friend of my sisters and I
met her when I was an aspiring, what I thought I was a writer.
I tried to be a writer. I wrote a screenplay. Uh,
it was a comedy film before I had the guts to go on stage.
And she was an aspiring actress and it's quite romantic really.
Cause I wrote a film about a love story, like a romantic comedy.
And my sister said, I think I've met the exact girl from the film you wrote.
So I sort of like created her. So we had a meeting about a big in this film.
Um, and she was literally the girl of my dreams. So, uh, yeah. Um,
a few years of begging and persuading and hiding in her garden later.
Um, and brushing my hair in front of my face and taking my glasses off. Um,
we got together and we'd been together for 20 years. Yeah.
So it's going really well.
[Inaudible] so she got together with her stalker. That's what happened? Yes.
That's exactly right.
That's exactly what happened. I,
it was one of the biggest shocks of my life when she said,
I think I'm falling in love with you because I thought she was about to call the
police again. It was extraordinary. Yeah.
Uh, tell me, how have you been touring in India as well?
India? No. No, I'm never in India. No.
So you never, you never,
you never dared to try India in there as too big for you or
why David has toured India. Yeah.
Please, please. Don't try. It were enough people there already.
I'm not welcome in India. No, no.
I've heard there was some gigs in India. I think in Delhi that people
in the UK were doing. Um, they never returned. So I don't know.
No, but would love to, I would love to, I would love to get an idea. Um,
you know, if they'll have me, it tends to be where people, you know,
invite me in. And then I find out that I might have an audience there.
And on occasion I find out that I don't.
What, what, David, what would be your advice to,
to Michael if he were to tour in India? What,
what is important to think about that?
Well, when I go up into stage in Delhi people, yes,
[inaudible], [inaudible].
Listen. When the pandemic's over David,
we're going to wrestle to find out who is this?
No, no, my advisor,
I haven't spent a half year now trying to pitch my show.
That's the name is the world's worst Indian in India.
So one piece of advice, don't name anything about worst Indian state?
They don't like that.
No, I won't do that. This and all this advice is great.
And I'd love to do a gig.
Anywhere, um, right now. But, but, but when you say that, I mean,
do you have to adapt to the culture in a way? Do you do, is it,
is it a big difference where you tour?
Well, that's it that, that helps really, because, you know,
I've lived in London my whole life and I have very few jokes about London,
but when you go to a new place,
you immediately see the differences and can just talk about them.
And they're just, they're just funny naturally. Um,
and they appreciate that you're paying attention. So actually it's much easier.
Um, I mean, I did, yeah.
I traveled around the whole world and then I ended up back doing these huge gigs
in London and I realized I didn't really have anything to start with because I
normally just start with, you know, um, local stuff, you know,
from where I am. Um, so, so yeah, no, that's,
that's a real benefit of, uh, of gig of performing around the world.
I think a typical fan, I don't know where,
w what's your typical fan in Scandinavia, but I know of one and that's more now,
uh, more than a year, a big Michael fan.
And I'm going to let you ask him a question. Now, if you have.
I want to be the unexpected star of the show.
This is so exciting.
Absolutely. Well, the problem is Muna is that now you know about it.
So I'm going to have to say that you won't be, but that, that means you will,
the unexpected, it needs to be, it needs to be expecting.
The last thing I can have, the unexpected star of the show is,
is expecting to be the unexpected stuff. So that's great that you,
you watch that show in Sweden. Yeah.
Can you please, can you please explain this more now? This is,
this is your business. Spend a lot of time with Michael. So explain this.
No, I, I sit alone.
In my home and I put on breath, BBC Brit.
And there he is. So every time when I'm feeling sad and lonely,
then Micah comes to say, you are the unexpected star.
So this is excellent. Well, I'm so thrilled. Yes. This is my TV show.
And I'm just finding out in this in real time that maybe the rights to that show
was shot sold to Sweden and maybe not Norway. So if you,
do you have them, do you have my show in Norway?
But you have the British and the BBC.
Yeah. We have to see it through all the channels. They were not having it. No.
Because I remember asking people in Norway,
what they watched from Britain and they watched like really old shows like
Bertia rack. Do you remember?
We love,
we love Virgin Bergerac is very much here and now for us.
Frederick, I mean, buzzer act was like from the seventies. I mean.
So, so relevant. It's so relevant.
So what, what shows do you watch? And everyone was just like.
No,
but we also have this pimple popping show that [inaudible] is
about Dr. Pimple popper.
Yes. I, my, my boys have watched this on YouTube. Um,
and so I would never watch this. This is a terrible, and they,
this pimple popping. Yes.
I, I don't know why it's successful. Um, because the,
the first time I went to Norway, they were those guys that did the Fox song.
Do you remember that one? What does it.
Yes. Yes. David has been working with them. Yeah.
Yes. And, and everyone was crazy. I thought, no,
it was one of the wildest places I'd ever been.
It was just people going budget act
done. So this is why I love you guys.
Tell me, uh, w if and when you're,
you're you're going on tour again, or do you, do you stay,
do you stay fit? Do you stay stage ready at all times?
Uh, no. No, no, no. I mean,
there's a short answer to that and it's no, the thing is, I always,
it's only when I'm on stage, I get so much energy. I'm very physical on stage,
but outside, outside of the stage, I mean, nothing really,
nothing even just to get to the stage, is it effort? Um,
but then as soon as I'm on the stage,
and that's why I injured myself all the time, because I do things in my buddies,
like, what are we doing? We don't do this. So I've literally I've hurt my arm.
I dislocated my shoulder on stage. I pulled muscles in my back and my leg.
I'm always injured. And I'm always wearing those heat patches, you know,
to try and get myself feel better. I need to get fit. We need to go shopping.
I need to get fit. This is all a plan.
So, but, but D D do you have any kind of pressure to, to,
to, to stay sort of, I mean,
we were talking about the looks of the autonomous area. I, we can agree.
He looks good.
John Thomas is one of the most attractive men I've ever seen in my life. Ah,
young Thomas danger. He's dangerous. Thank God.
We're separated by this huge distance.
My wife would be aware in a flash for young Thomas.
These teeth are so perfectly white. I was looking for sunglasses.
I could barely dazzled by young Thomas,
not quite as attractive.
I don't think you want to be sitting next to young Thomas.
You need to be sitting to me and then you'll look amazing.
I, I I'll keep the social distance for many reasons.
Yes. You'd need to socially distance to be a.
And then you might get a bit more excitement, but listen, DNS, Frederick.
I saw that you've got an audience.
They're all sitting together and they looked at me.
Yeah. In groups, in small groups, you know, they've had family groups, um, with,
with distance between the groups.
They're all in one family,
many, many small groups. I saw them.
They all sat with sitting in lines.
Did you advertise for the biggest family in Norway?
They're all Mormons. Well,
they must be nice to hear laughter I don't, I don't get to hear that anybody.
I mean, I can hear it a bit now, which is really thrilling. Please,
please enjoy it. Tell me.
Uh, I,
I read in some interview or something that your wife wants to send you to a
health farm just to shape and get
lose weight. What was that like? Did that work?
Well, I think, you know the answer because you can see me,
but, um, it did work actually, but then I did put the weight back on.
It was an inquiry. She basically said go away and come back, better looking.
So she sent me to Austria and um,
I lost a stone now. I don't know what to stone is in. What do you have?
Kilogram?
It's a lot. That's that's quite much. That's that's okay.
How long did that take?
Only a week. It was only a week and it costs lots and lots of money,
but it's amazing what they do. Oh, I can tell you how they do it.
It's incredible. They don't give you any food.
They literally just don't give you food. It's just full of my, you know,
when your tummy is chat, you know,
when your tummy you're hungry and your tummy rumbles, you know, when you're,
sometimes you're in bed and you hear it or,
you know, sometimes you comment on it. The whole of this whole everyone's,
it was like Jurassic park. Everybody was just
everyone's Tommy's was so hungry. And of course you lose weight.
So I lost a lot of weight and I nanny took legal action. I mean,
it was like a prison, but I did live pretty good for a bit.
I think you look great too. Thank you very much, Michael.
[inaudible] hope you enjoyed the clip for more interesting conversations,
please hit subscribe.